it's quite overwhelming thank you to the
members of the Academy for this honor my
dear friends who are here tonight Jenna
and George for your kind words to my
hero Louie Zamperini your cast of blood
and honey and most of all to my family
my love your support and your guidance
make everything that I do possible mad
I'm not going to cry I promise embarrass
you you and your brothers and sisters
are my happiness and there is no greater
honor in this world than being your mom
I'm very humbled to be here tonight
among so many extraordinary artists my
mother loved art she loved film she
supported any crazy thing I did but
whenever it had meaning she made a point
of telling me that is what film is for
and she never had a career as an artist
she never had the opportunity to express
herself beyond her theater class but she
wanted more than for herself she wanted
for Jamie and I to know what it is to
have a life as artists and she she gave
us that chance she drove me to every
audition and she would wait in the car
for hours always make me feel really
good all the times I didn't get the job
and when I did we would jump up and down
and scream and yell like little girls
she wasn't really the best critic since
she never had anything
unkind to say but she did give me love
and confidence and above all she was
very clear that nothing would mean
anything if I didn't live a life of use
to others and I didn't know what that
meant for a long time I came into this
business young and worried about my own
experiences my own pain and it was only
when I began to travel and look and live
beyond my home did I understand my
responsibilities to others when I met
survivors of war and famine and rape I
learned what life is like for most
people in this world and how fortunate I
was to have food to eat a roof over my
head a safe place to live
and the joy of having my family safe and
healthy and I realized how sheltered I
had been and I was determined never to
be that way again we are all everyone in
this room so fortunate I have never
understood why some people are lucky
enough to be born with the chance that I
had to have this path in life and why
across the world there's a woman just
like me with the same abilities and the
same desires same work ethic and love
for her family who would most likely
make better films and better speeches
only she sits in a refugee camp and she
has no voice she worries about what her
children will eat how to keep them safe
and if they'll ever be allowed to return
home I don't know why this is my life
and that's hers
I don't understand that but I will do as
my mother asked and I will do the best I
can with this life to be of use and to
stand here today means that I did as she
asked and if she were alive she'd be
very proud so thank you